welcome to thick boy fighters let's dive
in
saturday afternoon most valuable
promotions put out a lengthy press
release announcing that the august 6th
fight between jake paul and haseem
rahman jr has been cancelled the bout
scheduled to take place in new york
city's madison square garden reportedly
fell through due to alleged weight
deception on ramen junior's parts and
the promotion and good faith could not
continue with the fight
mvp and jake paul will not reward
someone that has conducted themselves in
such deceiving and calculated manner
therefore mvp is left with no choice but
to cancel the august 6th event jake paul
took to his personal instagram account
to relay the news first hand according
to paul he had already granted rahman
junior an extra five pounds over the
original greed weight
alrighty folks emergency press
conference you may have seen the news
hassem rockman jr has pulled out of the
fight this is not a joke i am devastated
i cannot [__] believe this here's
what happened long story short
so he signed a contract to fight me at
200 pounds and was gonna cut the weight
down to 200 pounds this is not a big cut
for him right
he's a big guy with a ton of weight to
lose
so he sent the video into the commission
the first time he weighed in at 216
pounds the commission wanted to track
his weight cut to make sure he was doing
it in a healthy way
three weeks later the commission asked
him for an update on his weight he sends
a video weighing 215 pounds meaning in
three weeks he only lost one pound so
the commission was like hey man you're
not cutting the weight properly we don't
want you to lose it all in the last day
we're gonna have to change this fight to
205 pounds
my team calls me up they're like hey man
would you want to change
they want to change the weight to 205
pounds i said no problem
let's do it i know i guess still beat
his ass at 205 pounds
and
that was that we move forward and then
today out of nowhere his team calls and
says hasim's not going lower than 215
pounds
if the fight's not at 215 pounds
then we're pulling out
my manager goes [__] you guys you're not
in control of this we already agreed to
five more pounds
a 10 pound weight cut for a heavyweight
is nothing
this is clearly an excuse so they say
okay the fight's not at 2 15 we're out
the biggest payday of his life times 10
and he's fumbling it
for what because he knows he's gonna get
knocked out by me the pressure starts to
set in and it's exactly what happens
with all of these guys in a series of
tweets rahman junior defended himself
and put the blame for the canceled bowed
on paul responding to a tweet from
boxing reporter dan raphael rahman jr
expressed that the fight was called off
before he could get a fair chance to cut
the weight why am i weighing in two and
three weeks before the fight daniel i
didn't even get a chance to hit the
scale on 8-5 like the contract said how
the fight off on me when they canceled
the event responding to a fan suggesting
the bout takes place as catch weight
between 200 and 214 pounds drama junior
said jake don't want that he'll only
take the fight if i agree to 200 or 205.
like we both said i was 215 yesterday
and i'm getting fined 25 per pound keep
the money i'm good with knocking him out
rahman junior finished his string of
tweets by simply saying time gonna
expose this boy trust me at the ufc 277
post fight press conference dana white
had some other theories on why the fight
between paul and rahm and junior had
been strapped
i think they sold under a million
dollars in tickets and it cost five
hundred thousand dollars to turn the
[__] lights on at madison square
garden that's what i think not to
mention hotel rooms in new york and
transportation and everything else is
very expensive
ufc 277 saw amanda nunez recapture the
bantamweight title and her double champ
status after she defeated juliana pena
saturday night in a five-round unanimous
decision the fight inspired conor
mcgregor to tweet a series of voice
notes comparing the nunes pannia series
to his fights with nate diaz
it's mad to me the similarity of last
night's
ladies bantamweight world title fight
rematch
tim one of the yes
the mcgregor diaz uh fights
fight number one
the highly touted
the goals the goal of the sport
sheer toughness
willingness to fight and caught off
guard
eat a couple of shots gives a couple of
shots then he eats a couple of shots
then the toy tournament then gets choked
now to return to rematch
yeah now
confidence on the other side
tenacity toughness all that's still
there
more focused work on the uh uh on the
noon as i saw it more he saw it
you know
and even at the end of the force even at
the end of the reason i'm even saying
this originally it's because the end no
i'm neither sorry i'm a fan of both
women you you i'm a huge fan of both of
both those women amanda nunes and
juliana pena and all everyone that steps
inside that [__] octagon to be honest
and
makes the
walk but at the end of the the original
belt
so i'm not surprised [__] and
then
again i'm not surprised [__]
juliana says it
and then
the exact stuff goes the exact same way
in the second for you drop multiple
times
just better prepared
cracks the shots gets the drop multiple
times but then the toughness you're
still there
it's still an amanda's face still on my
face some fights they are they're iconic
mixed martial arts belts that we're all
lucky to witness and it's mad that
you know double champ double champ
well i'm not surprised i'm not surprised
i don't know what to do
calabasas fight companion guest and
former ufc heavyweight matt mitrione
gave his exclusive ufc 277 fight
reaction to the thick boy fight news
team after the main card ended i thought
that uh brandon moreno looked really
good man uh he's aggressive he's very
efficient as far as striking goes um
i thought he had great distance on his
jabs very well prepared like he always
is
so i don't think that was much of a
surprise
then after that uh i think that i really
thought julianne pena was gonna win i
thought she's gonna put on a hell of a
show uh and she did as far as her gall
and her grit but she got her asking
pillar to post that's tough everybody
goes through it i got my ass beat pillow
to post by ryan vader so i get it
everybody's on the bad side sometimes
tonight just wasn't her night or tonight
was really amanda nunez's night she
looked great she looked fantastic and
she beat that ass the ufc's number one
ranked pound-for-pound fighter camaro
usman has secured his first movie role a
guest appearance in marvel's black
panther 2. former ufc double champ and
current ufc commentator daniel cormier
first broke the news during the ufc 277
weigh-ins and sources confirmed that
news with mmafighting.com on friday
usman's manager ali abdelaziz sent out a
series of tweets congratulating his
client the welterweight champ never
listen to nobody who says you can't
dream because this young boy from
nigeria his dreams are coming true all
you have to do is work hard at usman
past weeks have been great for usman
he's in thousands of gas stations across
the country with monster energy by next
week he's going to be in walmart
worldwide with pro sups today it was
made official he's going to be in the
next marvel studios black panther he
finished by tweeting a bold statement
putting usman at the top of three weight
classes and he's the baddest man on the
planet number one pound for pound he is
the best welterweight middleweight and
light heavyweight until anyone proves
otherwise the exact details surrounding
usman's role in the film are unknown
however fans can see him in action on
november 11th when the film hits
theaters and august 20th when he defends
his title against leon edwards looking
for more original mma content check out
the rest of thick boy youtube exclusive
interviews opinion and fight analysis is
available weekly on the shop show food
truck diaries and fight night flashbacks
subscribe so you don't miss any of the
action
you